[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture une émission pour
vous présenter les initiatives
culturelles du territoire
au programme aujourd'hui auteur
compositeur et interprète originaire de
rambouillet sabem sera avec nous pour
nous présenter son dernier album vers un
autre matin un troisième album composé
de 10 titres pop folk sorti en septembre
dernier la finale de la 6ème édition du
tremplin des voix aura lieu dimanche
l'événement verra s'affronter 18
candidats crise sanitaire obligé les
organisateurs ont dû s'adapter
un contenu 100% en ligne mais interactif
est prévue cette année
enfin un an après l'incendié qui a
ravagé son chapiteau la compagnie des
contraire nous ouvre ses portes
la présidence mais présentera le nouveau
chapiteau met en place et les projets de
la compagnie qui fête cette année ses 30
ans et je vous le disais en titre
l'artiste rambolitains fab m a sorti son
tout nouvel album en septembre dernier
il est intitulé vers un autre matin il
est composé de 13 titres sabem fonds
soit vous êtes avec nous aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter ce
nouveau projet c'est votre troisième
album
oui c'est un troisième album troisième
album un album un peu plus pop folk un
peu plus pop effectivement la production
il ya très ce titre il a été enregistré
en 2019 et voilà on l'a sorti sorti au
mois de septembre
pourquoi là pendant cette période de de
confinement voilà un album que j'ai
travaillé composer avec un tony larussa
harmonie principalement et
et voilà je suis assez fier de moi fier
de ce troisième album que j'ai ou bien
un peu plus un peu plus pop un peu plus
produit tout en mêlant des chansons à
texte qu'est ce qui représente justement
ce nouvel album pour vous ce nouveau
projet qui doit sortir
c'est vraiment un aboutissement puisque
j'avais mon deuxième album d'attac 2011
après un mini album un ep qui s'intitule
et demi de soleil en plus où j'avais
entamé un avis un virage un peu plus pop
là j'ai vraiment été au bout du bout de
mon idée je voulais vraiment j'ai une
influence de musicalement de souvent big
anglo saxon
j'aime bien leur façon produire la
musique que je voulais je voulais
relever entre guillemets le défi de
pouvoir mettre de la chanson la chanson
à texte tout en ayant une musique
musique un peu quels films musiques
dynamiques et efficaces et je suis
vraiment voilà huit y avoir des rendez
vous on est content du résultat j'espère
que ça va plaire ou es ce que vous avez
trouvé l'inspiration pour ses nouveaux
titres est ce que ça fait écho à des
situations personnelles
je pense par exemple à 21h44 21h44 en
fait pour la preuve cette histoire c'est
moi qu'on parlait cette chanson là
puisque c'est celle instrumental qui qui
qui qui ouvre l'album et ça enchaîne
avec une chanson qui s'appelle 50 ans
aujourd'hui on a un homme d'un homme qui
fête son anniversaire de tableau et
21h44 j'ai choisi ouais ça pouvait être
pas plus pour ne pas être plus
personnelle puisque sa date de naissance
de ma fille et à l'heure de naissance
marcoux l'heure de naissance
je vous propose d'écouter un des traits
ce titre qui est de l'album s'intitule
meilleur espoir féminin puis on en parle
juste après
fromage de monts
[Musique]
bords de seine
ap m
lesquels
tu verras
dans la rue
paris
mais
[Musique]
on vient donc d'écouter un extrait de
meilleur espoir féminin qui fait partie
du coût des 13 titres de l'album quelle
est l'histoire de ce titre qu'est ce que
ça raconte ce titre il est alors cet
album là il ya trois textes que j'ai
coécrit texte que j'ai co écrit par don
avec avec françois terral en amérique
iger j'ai écrit déjà d'autres titres
auparavant
il est venu avec cette idée de meilleur
espoir féminin c'est l'histoire d'un
amoureux qui serait un petit peu au
hasard il ya une métaphore entre entre
cet homme qui est qui et qui est fou
amoureux d'une femme et on y met plein
de métaphores autour du cinéma on s'est
amusé là dessus alors est ce que cet
homme est juste en train de rêver du
moment qu'il est qui voudraient passer
avec elle et à chaque fois on a line est
clair une description de ce qu'on peut
avoir aux césars par l'ampleur le
meilleur décor le meilleur mais ton
meilleur dialogue meilleur scénario et
il lui s'invente un peu son petit film
autour de autour de autour de cette
femme dont il est amoureux et on s'est
vraiment amusé pour ce faire une chanson
là dessus et pour le clip on a on a
voulu mettre un peu l'honneur
me voilà enfin les femmes et surtout
surtout surtout dans ad on ad on a des
femmes assez exceptionnel conquis
pratique chacun un arrêt et qui sont
complètement authentique donc on a
profité cette chanson là pour aussi d'un
joli clip hey hey hey mettre en avant
des danseuses des performeuses donc
voila c'était une jolie histoire et pour
terminer en quelques mots faber du coup
vous incarner des personnages un peu
avec ces différents titres
oui c'est ça c'est s'il ya vraiment
plusieurs plusieurs tableaux le court je
dis je parle d'un homme d'un homme de 50
ans je parle bien sûr de 20 jeux ne m'a
pas là j'ai pas été chercher très loin
pour l'inspiration il ya ya ya
je parle aussi des sites de rencontre de
deux amoureux qui feint de 2-2-2 être
encore seul qui qui qui tarde à se
rencontrer
j'essaie de faire vraiment quelques
quelques tableaux de vie de deux choses
qu'on a pu lui raconter de choses que
j'ai pu observer je suis assez sensible
aux relations humaines et ce qui
m'inspire
effectivement il ya plusieurs il ya
plusieurs comédiens plusieurs facteurs
voilà c'est du simple l'histoire cet
album merci femmes aiment pour ces
précisions et merci d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir je le rappelle votre album
est disponible donc sur toutes les
plateformes en ligne en magasin et bien
sûr sur votre site internet fabienne
point fr oui beaucoup
merci à vous et bonne soirée c'est
bientôt la grande finale du de la 6e
édition du tremplin des voix donc on
reste dans la musique
les 18 candidats sélectionnés pourront
exprimer leurs talents vocaux ce
dimanche 31 janvier à 18 heures le
concours de chant habituellement
organisées dans les yvelines par
l'association est la voie en scène
propose un contenu sont % en ligne cette
année les organisateurs ont souhaité
rendre l'événement plus interactif
les spectateurs pourront donc commenter
et noter les participants en live
quand ils vont aller sur ce lien il va
voir ben sur leurs téléphones tablettes
ordinateurs donc un espèce de plateforme
où ils vont pouvoir voter pour les
candidats c'est pas seulement voter pour
le candidat qu'on vient soutenir c'est
voter pour tous les candidats donc c'est
ludique
c'est le moment de découvrir des
nouveaux talents et en plus de
participer puisque c'est interactif
on peut envoyer des commentaires de
donner un peu son avis les lauréats
seront donc contacté dans la soirée pour
savourer en direct leur victoire parmi
les différentes récompenses un suivi
personnalisé par exemple sur l'année des
séances de coaching ou encore
l'enregistrement deux maquettes au maroc
c'est le nom du dernier livre de
françois xavier goudemand cet ouvrage
parler des origines de sang un nom de
groupe rock et célia agathon gouffre et
technique ce soir pour en parler mon
sort
vous avez justement parlé avec le perdre
au maroc oui alors a cédé 6 sur
metallica ou encore téléphone c'est non
même si on n'est pas forcément fan de
rock on les a au moins entendu une fois
vous justin en tant que grande fan de
rock et est ce que vous connaissez leurs
origines
c'est vrai qu'on connaît pas toujours
l'origine des maux et bien françois
xavier goudemand l'auteur est l'habitant
il ya un habitant de noisy le roi a
voulu les décrypter pour chaque nom de
groupe une anecdote insolite lui est
associée comme par exemple pour le
groupe muse muse signifie normalement
multi unit spectre onic explorer même
quelque chose de très particulier qui
est un instrument astronomique équipant
notamment les grands télescopes le lit
de front tu as essayé de se dire qu'il
fallait de toute les façons quelque
chose de mémorisable mais vraiment de
traits singuliers à raconter autour de
autour de ce nom et donc ce livre célia
cartonne sur amazon vie il varie entre
la première et la deuxième place des
ventes sur amazon dans la rubrique rock
hard rock et métal
je suis je suis ravi et ça prouve ça
prouve qu'aujourd'hui la musique la
musique rock en général intéresse
beaucoup beaucoup de gens et pas
uniquement les boumeurs dans la vie
françois xavier goudemand est brand
experts il s'intéresse à la construction
des noms de marques
il a d'ailleurs écrit l'an dernier un
branding rockstar un livre qui mêle le
marketing des marques et les rock stars
et c'est quoi alors un bon nom de marque
c'est bien il a d'abord il faut savoir
que la langue anglaise est très souvent
utilisé est d'après l'auteur il ya cinq
points d'ancrage pour un bon groupe un
bon nom c'est comme une grande marque
il faut qu'ils soient audibles illisible
identifiable mémorable mémorisable et au
mali au maroc sociales yves reconnecter
oui puisque sur chaque page
il y à un qr code est donc si vous ne
connaissez pas le groupe vous accédez
directement à sa page officielle sur
youtube et donc à la fin du livre il ya
aussi un 23 heures de musique qu'il
suffit de flasher codé avec son
smartphone est ce qu il ya de nouveaux
projets en route et bien l'écrivain
travaille sur un prochain livre qui
sortira normalement un set était un
roman biographique sur une très grande
star de musique
merci c'est diakhaté nouveau d'avoir été
avec nos journalistes pour tv 78 on vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro
mais avec plaisir très berne en
apprennent un fonds dit de son chapiteau
la compagnie des contraire nous ouvre
ses portes
implantée à chanteloup-les-vignes
aujourd'hui à la compagnie continue son
travail de cirque social et regarde vers
l'avant
présidente de la compagnie justement
nous présentent leur galerie à ciel
ouvert et c'est nouveau chapiteau
bienvenue chez la compagnie de contraire
maintenant je vais vous présenter notre
chapiteau le repaire de contraire donné
le 2 novembre 2019 le château de la
compagnie des contraire été victime d'un
incendie avec le soutien de la région
ile de france
elle a pu racheter et mettre en place un
nouveau chapiteau dans la période de
transition qui a eu les ateliers de
cirque on continue et on a eu un
partenariat avec le collège magellan qui
nous accepter et l'économie le visage et
on n'a pas du tout arrêter le travail
jusqu'à l'implantation de chapiteaux le
repère des contraires prépare à toutes
les disciplines du cirque et permet
l'expression artistique
objectif rendre la culture accessible à
tous un travail d'insertion sociale
toujours la campagne était en cirque
social et nous sommes une équipe
d'artistes engagés est vraiment pour le
développement de l'éducation populaire
surtout dans les quartiers sensibles
autre projet de la compagnie le cabanon
une galerie à ciel ouvert implanté en
2008 il a marqué le début du repaire des
contraires depuis une dizaine d'artistes
à travailler dessus ça c'est devenu
voilà notre galerie
si vous pouvez voir le travail de
sandrine avant guerre
c'est une mosaïste ça c'était un travail
d'insertion qui a commencé en 2017
la compagnie des contraires fêtera ses
30 ans le 11 juillet prochain
part à des manifestations seront
organisées à cette occasion et le monde
de la bd a perdu le créateur de michel
vaillant jean graton est décédé à ce 21
janvier à 97 ans michel vaillant était
sa principale série une saga familiale
dont il a signé 70 albums auteur et
dessinateur jean graton aura marqué la
bande dessinée mais pas que marc bourne
dessinateur et scénariste yvelinois nous
en parle il a participé au dessin de six
albums
de la nouvelle saison et nous présente
cet artiste novateur et d'avoir un coup
de pinceau assez extraordinaire il ancre
et ou au pinceau par les graphistes les
dessinateurs seront de quoi je parle
c'était un dessinateur qui étaient
sous-estimés parce qu'on a tendance à le
dire que ces personnages avaient tous la
mâchoire carrée il y avait tous un peu
la même tête mais mais il faut voir il
faut étudier attentivement son graphisme
pour voir la force qu'il avait et le
l'innovation aussi dans le traitement de
la vitesse le traitement du mouvement et
la narration fin c'était un très grand
auteur de bandes dessinées qui marquera
l'histoire de la bdl qui a créé en plus
un personnage mythique qui qui est sorti
des cases de bande dessinée puisque
michel veillon il ya eu des vaillantes
qui ont couru au mans un personnage
mythique donc y aurait en fait dépassé
les barrières de la bande dessinée avec
une grande notoriété notamment dans le
milieu du sport automobile
et c'est la fin de cette fuite culture
merci de nous avoir suivis et à bientôt
et bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]